[Musik]
jedes schweiz im gefängnis sie im
schnitt ein weltuntergang ein reporter
kollege christof franzen und ich gehen
für eine woche in die jva aachen schieß
ich bin hinter der kamera die er davor
die banalität des bösen
ja
aber die komplexität ist
ich berichte seit über zehn jahren über
justizthemen er ist zum ersten mal in
einem schweizer gefängnis
für die gesellschaft halten wir es mögen
so ist es
sie haben drogen in den drogenhandel ich
bin vierter mal glauben gast
wir wollen herausfinden was es bringt
menschen zu strafen
und in verurteilt wurde zu sechs jahren
und
bandenmäßiger einbruchdiebstahl
ich habe anzeige wegen vorsätzlicher
tätig also in zukunft in gang geraten
aber das messer mit oskar
sehen sie das das hat mir der kopf
braucht das
make it rain
was wäre ohne gefängnis anarchie und
asche
strafe muss sein sozusagen weil er krank
machen oder more träger der muss
bezahlen und das system gibt es seit eh
und je gefängnis behinderte sind gerade
sie jetzt ist sie so
auf ein zweites hotel anmutet so zusage
am ende des tages auch du allein die
zahl armer
und das spielt sie zum studieren
zeit um zum beispiel darüber
nachzudenken wieso er auf die schiefe
bahn geraten ist
wieso erst einen platz in unserer
gesellschaft mit 30 jahren noch immer
nicht gefunden hat
wieso er anfing zu stehlen und
schließlich zum serien einbrecher wurde
mehr als auch finanzieller ist
ausschlaggebend sie warum es so wie
traurig dass ich jetzt da bin ich an
geld braucht und ich bin so ein mensch
ich bin bereit für geld fast alles zu
machen
viel geld löse die probleme hat
rückschlags christa mangel
an schlechte gewissen fordert darum
wirklich dass ich tat so machen dass es
greife letzte gibt und gleichzeitig die
lützow zu sagen darum habe ich die art
von kriminalität gewarnt
honig kreis kontakt haben mit dem
anderen
potro mit anfang 20
kurz vor seinen letzten verhaftung
[Musik]
wollte doch ich werde so mit blut und
tränen ich will mich immer für was sich
das coolste was unter dem er begann sich
einen namen aus schlepper zu machen
daneben brauche quasi im akkord in
geschäftsliegenschaften ein und
finanzierte sich so seinen aufwendigen
lebensstil
[Musik]
mit lügen
es war ja immer und zwar mit mit grün
ins heim kommt und zwar aus auf die
biografie das
kinderheim bild geboren hat das reiße
und daran ist vor allem zu
heimflug familienzuschlag familie und
eine
bis man es waren der kriminelle
weggeschlagen
und nachher ist vor allem an statt heim
ist nachher zu geschlossene oder krank
ist oder
jugendstrafanstalten
besonders keinen dem land
mehr oder weniger ja aber sie sagen
[Musik]
er wurde wegen mordes zu 18 jahren
verurteilt
zehn jahre hat er schon verbüßt
der vermögensverwalter heute 67 habe
einen flüchtigen bekannten angst
nächster nähe erschossen
sein motiv geld und verletzter stolz
dass jetzt sehr forsch wie daheim
jaja man hören sich daraus ich einfach
ich philosophie heimat steht wo man sich
befindet
oder sagen wir es ist wohl fühlt ich
glaube einfach da und ich habe mich
immer gut auf turniere haben in
verschiedenen lampen
hat sich sehr mobil xi raten von ddr
sports nicht nur schwer ein
psychologisch und vor allem vom
allmählichen gisler bug an bug und
von daher spielt das eine rolle
von goethe
ließ sich einfach in einem drei
perspektiven iran früher nur 16 stunden
berg geschafft bin eigentlich halben
durchstart xi und für möglich dass ein
krieg männer eine erholungsphase
honig auch mich anzogen
im alter was alles abkommen haben dass
uns arbeiten und verarbeiter und dass
sich ein positiver aspekt
und wir haben da immer sehr kontakt mit
dem
fahrrad zum allgemeine lebensfragen und
des sehr guten ansprechbar
der zentrale punkt
und wie geht das mit dem dort zusammen
mit
seiner katze noch ein anderer nachbar
kritisch bestritt jedoch oder gefühle da
was aus
als unschuldiger dass ein justizopfer
solche geschichten hören wir hier viele
menschen die sich als opfer sehen
menschen die sich ungerecht behandelt
fühlen menschen die sagen sie seien
harmlos und sollten darum sofort
entlassen werden
[Musik]
aber es wäre mir selbst sagen wie sehr
partie es ist mit gefühlen tragen
torwart sven oder motorisch habe ich ja
nur rote lichter
blenden oder und schnitzt viel habe ich
mit ruine und drehte viertelstunde
unterhalb sturm mit dem und da kann ich
das sicher bessere schätze aus alten
positionen mit denen personen befasst
sind
[Musik]
so jetzt für elternlose gerichtet das
muss auch die wohnliche und heimlich sie
wird verbringt man viel zeit
und manchmal viel zieht deine verbringt
soldaten haben sie und zerstöre
mitwisser wand und
familie foto das ist privat wie andere
insassen und user die ein bisschen
unbedingt mit
überholen nach der frau ferner sind mit
also ist einzigartig
ist das wird das ist nunmal
vor dem knast stammten die frauen
schlange sagt ihr
dass ich nicht
im bett klinik konnten
er wähnte sich auf der überholspur
höher schneller weiter
ein leben im scheinwerferlicht ohne
geldsorgen alles schien möglich
also normaler job das brauchen immer
möglich
ist schwierig mit einem neuen und
zeugnis wie zu tags der migros kasse
musst du von uns zu rücken ist anlegen
also es wird der raum ist die
baustelle schwarzarbeit aber das ist
auch schon wieder illegal also es gab
immer
quasi
aber etwas probiert ja ich habe mich auf
dem rasen herum ist die 12 bewerber pro
monat abschied ist eine gemachte befehl
meine plan und ich an jedem monat 12
absagen
und ein immer gemerkt eigentlich ist
also ein vorgeblicher blockmodells stadt
immer
dass ich andere besser qualifiziertes
personal beworben hat wissen wir ihnen
eine absage erteilen blabla also nie als
vorstellig sprache
absage woran merkt dass ich definitiv am
leumundszeugnis
das
resort ist
noch wie wählte der schritt von dort zur
strafe wieder mit der ehemalige kollegen
ja fakt ist wenn ich die anderen acht
findet 12 30 franken gemacht haben nach
sehe ich für vier du siehst du hier halb
auf dem ball der ganze monat
und ich kam gut rüber es gibt so einfach
in wenigen also
und die regale ganz groß und schwer und
steinig
es gibt die macher der entscheidende
schritt getraut sich quasi die rote
linie überschritten
anderes hat diese rote linie in der
vergangenheit immer wieder überschritten
dritter ebenfalls der gebürtige serbe
39 hat im großen stil mit heroin
gehandelt
in der hoffnung auf das schnelle geld
in einer tag
die haben mir verhaftet mit neun kilo
muss der zahlen 200.000
das heißt es geht raus
leider nicht gekommen diese gefängnis
ich bin gegangen mehr kriminell sowie
handy war aus wieso man sieht die ganze
zeit und ganze zeit verbringt man
wie kann ich draußen wieder etwas neues
machen
außer etwas kriminelles
zum beispiel einbrecher einem
wassereinbruch
wer solche extras mal
und am ende man bargeldlos
polizei ist verdienen schon
und man lerne die dreamcast mögliche
strafe schreckt nicht ob meine stoffe
meine meinung als ich oder sogar
gefängnis hier der schweiz
erschreckt nimmt die reine geschraubt
zwei jahre
ereignet
haben strafen eine abschreckende wirkung
und lässt sich diese wirkung mit
härteren strafen steigern
diese fragen gehören zu den am besten
erforschten themen der kriminologie und
die antworten sind klar erfahren wir
unter rechtswissenschaftlichen fakultät
der universität fribourg
es wird funktionieren das würde mir
wünschen dass werden sondern als es
keine strafe weniger straf und haben das
verhalten stört es ein problem ist dass
das halt einfach menschliche seite
extrem komplex ist warum ist das so
warum funktioniert das nicht das
funktioniert nicht darum weil er
eigentlich mit meinem manager sind da
einfach nicht die bühne zum gast basiert
zum nur was passiert sondern auch
einfach mal das haben wir möglich sehr
gut mps navis und manager keine technik
das heißt die meisten menschen wüssten
nicht was passiert sie müssen irgendwie
durchschnitt so erlaubt das müsste
normalerweise bereifung ein strafrecht
müsse man darf nicht der verletzte
spieler und sowie das alles nicht aber
was genau passiert wie es nicht wenn
jetzt also die strafsteuer von fünf
studie aber setzen oder für fünf jahre
auch die rufe setzt hat überhaupt keine
post von otto sieber jahr ist einfach
sehr lang und die
empirie ist also eindeutig
trotzdem sind und bleiben diese fragen
ein medialer dauerbrenner pflegen wir
hierzulande die kuscheljustiz naiv und
wirkungslos braucht es tatsächlich mehr
härte und strengere gesetze
zu teuer zu milde manchmal brauche es
statt kuscheljustiz einfach die ganz
harte tour härtere strafen sollen
dagegen jetzt helfen der nationalrat
debattiert morgen darüber sie scheint
politisch kapital mache für kein
priester
geldstrafe setzte
wenn ich mir relativ sicher bin dass ich
schon entdeckt wird und verfolgt wird
das spielt doch dass überhaupt ein
tägliches wahrscheinlichkeit und
bestraft wahrscheinlichkeit sind
zentraler faktor
was genau passiert spielt gar keine
rolle also wie viel genau auf das er
geht er wieder straff geht über spielt
überhaupt keine rolle
zentral ist dass es überhaupt eine
strafe gibt und zwar schnell
wenn wir nur höhere strafe gab aber in
der ökonomie jahr gabe erschreckt das
andere ab das
ist nicht der fall also ein mensch das
war bis jetzt keine
details wenn man härtere strafen androht
dann werdet weniger auffällig wenn sie
angestellt vor der strafe und logik
punkt 2 wenn wir die ritter oder
griechen machen wenn man die langley
spüren dann diktiert das noch und beide
spieler verfügen
die politik da war das vor und oder
glied die fortbewegung unterstützen ob
die wirklich also mitdenken doch
schrecklich dass man auch immer sichere
roland glaubt oder ob es mehr emotionale
reaktion ist wenn man sie müssten
einfach
die meisten einfach sind heftig die
werden wir nicht in der gesellschaft
also wird ihnen zur strafe die freiheit
entzogen
und sie landen bei andreas nickel dem
direktor der jva pöschwies hier soll aus
ihnen bessere menschen machen indem er
sich zum beispiel zusätzlich bestraft
wenn sie sich nicht an die hier
geltenden regeln halten
fehlverhalten wird hier schnell und
konsequent sanktioniert mit maximal 20
tagen oder ist das jetzt für
für die ganze der fall als härtefall
sondern
[Musik]
eine reststrafe warum aber es gibt aber
viele sagen das prüfteam ii vor dem da
schon interessant dass hier sagt das
wird quasi machen terno
wird liegt die ganze person eines
himmels willen dass er das schon auch
relativ wenig älter als er selbst aus
denn
anders verstanden
sie gehören also wieder heimisch sie
gehörte der sich selber oder das absolut
oder das ist ja nicht wegen das ist eine
gegend die als freundliche yoga oder
von dem her ist das sicher nicht
dass mein mann
gegen java
ist bedeutet 23 stunden pro tag in der
zelle und eine stunde hofgang
wenn man sich vorstellt dass
spezielle kontraste
[Musik]
strafe muss sein sagt nägeli strafe sei
aber nur ein teil auf dem weg zur
besserung
[Musik]
natürlich auch nicht vor den ausbruch
die sicht das war das ideal wurde
unterschrieben auf jeden fall die höfe
geesthacht oft oder das audi angebaut wo
mir warum ihr bietet oder sekt das von
lehrerschaft entgegnete alltag als ein
hat eigene struktur war ein halt gibt
und man hat
natürlich der sieg von personal
professionelle lüth wo auch ein vorbild
was dann so gesellschaftlich erwartet
und akzeptiert wird so vom normaler
mensch
[Musik]
hätten wir 20
die lage schon hier ist jetzt einbaut
und forschung jugend
kleinigkeit aber nicht mit großen was
sind das lediglich
habe ich mal mit service oder so aber
sie nehmen ihr gravierend die vorfall
bisher mit 18 im ausgang mit einem
messer auf zwei junge männer ein stark
dabei ist die
provokation oder ja es ist gang und dann
hat das angefangen hat sich versuch
werkelt und auch als junge musste sich
daraus mehr will und was man will und
muss man wirklich meine bedingung
spinnst du schießt
aber ist energie in wien amerikanische
krank ist findet dass man erst mal die
zahlen kurve werden dann wird eine sehr
schöne zugabe muss gleich
sagen wir so es bewusst sagst du wirst
du suchst dir hilft das ja zur
abschreckung
sie sind ja damit geschlossen es sind ja
nicht das ist jetzt kein verbot
mannschaft hast zum teil hüten die
nächstgrößte zügige überlegt nur zweimal
und das ist jetzt schon sagen sich die
gesellschaft das werde aber nicht besser
ich meine mal passt sich automatisch ein
unfall dauern sind natürlich das jahr
machen können sie sich abkoppeln kann
sie das eigentlich war ja damit machen
das hinterlässt spuren
[Musik]
für andere massiv hier
ich bin glaube immer noch der gleiche
das ist gar nicht vermisst natürlich
muss ich sagen kulturell ist für mich
aber es bringt mich nicht um und ich
habe einen hund ich bin sehr nach auch
die frau ist pink ich bin sehr nach
außen orientiert im prinzip leipzig in
nürnberg und das ist für mich da ihnen
auto fall ich glaube für mich die mir
ich bin bei mir und das doppelte so
berühren was alles was abgeht
ich bin das nicht seit 20 jährige der
mit einer blauen jeans autos gestohlen
wie mit deiner flagge fahren und dann
sie nach hersteller und kann nicht
wissen was mal fangen mit deiner autos
hupten bevor ich kontakt
bin ich quasi jetzt dran das auto
verscherbelt geld die schiefe zähne
umlackiert und
ab die post
jetzt war die sache jetzt werde es weder
hat auch die familien an blickkontakt da
bin ich wieder drogen nicht mit der
waffe alles ist jetzt möglich daheim
sind
aber natürlich ist der weg als erstes
legal das ist klar
aus amateuren können hier drin also
profi verbrecher werden das ziel des
strafvollzuges ist freilich ein anderes
diese menschen auf die freiheit
vorzubereiten und das in einem umfeld
das mit der freiheit wenig bis nichts zu
tun hat
die jetzt saniert die
revanche
für eine koch- oder am ende gar die
realen zahlen wenn ein konflikt hatte
haben sich auf sehr viele professionelle
lüth wenn
dort die jetzt wo gut dotiert ist wo man
also quasi lebens straße zum doktor
seelische not hat haben ihre sorgen oder
seelsorger sozialarbeiter die vorzugs
mitarbeiter an kompetenzen also das ist
ja in der freiheit dann schon so dass
man aber schwebt und dann gucken wie er
seinen glauben zu netzwerk von lytro
wurden professionell miamis problems
lösen und und da dann wieder bereit
standen verliert normal aber das verrät
das verehrte um diesem problem zu
begegnen erfolgt der strafvollzug wenn
immer möglich progressiv von einer
geschlossenen anstalt gibt es irgendwann
in eine offene
immer mehr freiräume sollen helfen sie
schrittweise wieder in die gesellschaft
einzugliedern
giorgio hatte diese chance auch
bewährte sich allerdings nicht im
offenen vollzug
darum ging es zurück in die
geschlossenheit
der lehrer mache ich das nie ste maxi
noch eine lehre machen daher habe ich
das viel tierisches die option ein leben
ohne
das sind so sagte pele rheine oder an
lehrern da hast du mich war nicht
automechaniker alleine sondern nur
reifen praktiker aber immerhin
schon darüber gartner
ich kann ihnen jetzt konnte sie sowieso
unter dem umstand ihnen
muss ich mich auf andere sachen
konzentrieren
klaro verhalten da ist man klar mit
im strafvollzug herrscht arbeitspflicht
es gibt verschiedene einfache haben wir
kriege gewerbe
[Musik]
was wenn das scheint ihn abholt sonntag
nochmals becker
anfang meine familie mitnehmen lüftung
ich hoffe dass ich ja dass ich am
wichtigsten ist dass das ist dass man
den kontakt so dass man jetzt in die
symbole überfällig das ist wichtigsten
bühnen ins prozent satellit oder denen
sie zu fragen wie diese werden später
und dann muss man fragen was hat mir
verglüht war einfach bis zuletzt
geschlossene vollzug sie sind oder
ludwig die chance kannst es dann wieder
zurück zu ihrer familie wo sich alle
schnell los ich hätte die möglichkeit
videos jetzt
kriegt wird nach seiner entlassung angst
geschafft und will in serbien noch mal
ganz neu anfangen
eigentlich wurde niemand leer wendungen
was
und dann mann kennen die leute war
zusammen eine rigide haltung sondern mit
drin
dann ist zu spät aber das ist wie eine
kleine schneeball
man kommt rein und man ist nicht so
einfach rausgehen aber
so ein normales leben haben mit frau
kindern oder so damals kamen gehabt
jetzt ich habe eine frau und ein kind
das wäre doch ein grund um nicht mehr
zurückzukommen das wäre von mir in der
serie großer grund das niemals so tun
etwas so gehen zum leben eine normale
leben
wie die war rund 20 jahre
[Musik]
strafen können wirken sie können aber
auch schaden ob sie müssen sein
und es braucht einen ort wo sie
vollzogen werden das sind seit jeher
gefängnisse
das bestätigt die gesellschaft ein stück
wird und das ist legitim
darum dass cordes um seine stücke also
um raucher aber dass man das so wegnimmt
du kannst sie dann noch vermutlich stehe
oder mach's mit um das macht des staates
im namen vor seiner mit dem und wenn es
nicht macht
wie erfolgreich ist der zürcher
strafvollzug darüber hinaus eine studie
zeigt etwa jeder siebte gewalt und
sexualstraftäter wird rückfällig die
große mehrheit der gefangenen sind
allerdings ausländer und die werden nach
der entlassung aus geschafft ihre
rückfälligkeit also gar nicht erfasst
ein paar wochen später wir sind zurück
in der jvp schließt porsche war
ja hier bis nach
georgia hat seine strafe bis auf den
letzten tag abgesessen
heute wird er entlassen
überredet letzter stunde
eine träne schlafen ganz nach der
marktlage halbe links rechts links die
gäste jetzt muss es fast gar üben wie
ein abschied minute wilde
anschluss übertritt von klassik mit so
positiven
kontrolle auf thc
[Musik]
das ist quasi von null auf hundert
musste zahlen ohne fernseher direkt
also die ängste kollegen
und er ist wo die leiche angeordnet
leute kommen leute gehen
ich bin der rundgang riesig sind
also nach sieben jahren
statt es ist wie wenn so ein riesenstein
von der schulter und fühlt sich
gut
auf
das ist alles ein ganzes hab und gut vor
der letzten sieben jahre bilder schmeckt
noch
keine bilder
ein kollege erwartet ihn vor dieser tür
und natürlich auch die freiheit
[Musik]
ob ihnen die freiheit vor
so noch nicht da erst mal
vermutlich
also hey wo ich das
zumindest österreich dann
kann ich doch ganz viele bunte scheine
sehen sie das das hat mir der knall
sprach das
make it rain
jetzt wird investiert
ich weiß noch wie geht
eigentlich eine grüne
teppich ich hoffe jährigen apple meldet
sich bei mir und bietet mir den job
alles
kümmern wo dann dreckigen
das gefühl wird klären
ich hoffe es
nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]